et
bonjour bienvenue dans un nouvel épisode
de montre moi un signe souvent les
personnes demandent leur chemin aux
passants pas toujours facile lorsqu'il
faut signer pour se faire comprendre
mais pour nous ce n'est pas un problème
je vais vous montrer comme un bonjour à
vous est sourde
d'accord vous lisez sur les lèvres
doucement je cherche la mairie la mairie
ouiiiii la mairie
à droite
tous droits
et après
difficile de lui expliquer peut-être que
j'ai signé un peu trop vite le signe
pour aller à droite le signe pour aller
tout droit le signe pour aller à gauche
je vais essayer de lui expliquer plus
lentement pour voir si elle comprend à
droite
d'accord
tous droits
le rond point d'accord à gauche
d'accord et je vois
bon
la pharmacie
la pharmacie d'accord
à côté la mairie d'accord
merci au revoir les entendants et les
sourds ont le même permis de conduire
le moniteur parfois c'est signé ou bien
il met en place un interprète qui
m'explique
et c'est clair moi je suis sourde mais
j'ai le sens très développé de
l'observation
quand je conduis je regarde partout et
aussi je ressens les vibrations
par exemple quand je sens que ça ronfle
alors je change de vitesse
bonjour montre moi un signe direction à
droite tout droit
à gauche
rond-point pharmacie
mary permis de conduire au revoir
e
et
vous